-Welcome back. Good to see you.
-Thank you so much.
-I'm always so happy to have you
here. You did a very nice thing.
In your hometown of
Traverse City, Michigan,
you own a couple movie theaters.
Beautiful --
-Some old theaters.
I restored them as a nonprofit
and donated them
to the community, yeah.
-During the shutdown,
you were letting federal workers
come for free.
-Yes. Yeah.
And their families.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Free popcorn, free pop.
-Free popcorn and free pop.
That's great.
-Yes. Yes.
-Wait. You guys
call popcorn pop?
-No. Soda is pop.
-All right. Good.
-Popcorn is popcorn.
-Okay. Good.
I was worried there was, like,
some weird Traverse City slang.
-No, no, no. We are --
The closer you get to Canada,
words do change.
-Yeah.
-And people get nicer.
-They do. The closer you get
to Canada, they get nicer.
I want to thank you. You gave us
some very nice promotion.
You wore a "Late Night
with Seth Meyers" hat
on "All In with Chris Hayes."
-Oh, that's right.
I promised I'd wear
a Chris Hayes hat tonight.
-Oh, really?
-Oh, I'm so -- He's in bed.
-Oh, yeah. He won't be...
You know what we'll do?
We'll just digitally
put in there.
We'll get our digital-effects
team to make it a...
Yeah, there you go.
[ Laughs ]
So, we have so much
to talk about.
We were obviously mentioning
Howard Schultz
at the top of the show.
How do you feel about --
-The self-made Howard Schultz.
-Well, now, explain this.
-Yes, yes.
-You take issue with
"self-made."
-Well, in the same sentence,
he goes,
"I'm a self-made billionaire.
I grew up in the projects
in Brooklyn."
Right away, by admitting
that you had subsidized
public housing
paid for by the tax dollars
of the American people,
you aren't self-made.
You got a hand up from us,
like we want to do.
We want to help
our fellow Americans.
It's a form of socialism,
public housing.
And yet he's saying,
"I'm all self-made."
He went to a public university.
He went to Northern Michigan
University, actually.
And, you know, again,
financed by taxpayers' dollars.
And, then, he sells coffee,
which is essentially water,
using city water systems.
-Yeah.
-Municipal water systems.
-Right.
-Which, you know...
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's, like,
a huge infrastructure
that, you know,
if you have a business,
you might have to
have FedEx or trucks
deliver things to your store.
He has the people in New York
and all these other cities
delivering the water
underground to him.
And, then, you know
what your water bill is.
Nobody -- It's --
Of all the utility bills,
it's your least expensive bill,
right?
So, I did the calculation
earlier today.
It's like 100th of a penny
to fill up a grande cup
at Starbucks.
100th of a penny for that water.
And to say,
"Oh, I got to be a..."
You got to be a billionaire
because we're paying
for the water!
-Yeah. Yeah.
If he was just giving people
a cup of coffee grounds,
that would be one thing.
-The beans are probably
another penny.
The coffee bean.
-You have a way --
You have an idea
to pressure him not to run.
What's your idea?
-Well, my idea, first of all,
is none of us
should go to Starbucks until
he announces he's not running.
-Gotcha. Okay.
-Then you can go back
and buy a $5 cup of coffee.
But in the meantime,
I was thinking
that those of us who would
support such a boycott,
we could set up, like, a little
table in front of Starbucks,
like a lemonade stand,
and provide coffee,
because people need their
coffee, I understand that.
So, we'll have coffee
there at Starbucks
but in front of Starbucks
with city-owned water.
-There you go.
-So...
-Again, we're starting to see --
You know, it's still early days.
There's sort of a trickle
of candidates
that I think is going to
only increase in size.
We're starting to see platforms.
If you were running,
what would be your platforms?
What would be the things
that Michael Moore would promise
to the American people?
-Well, I have a number of things
I would do.
First of all, I love the idea
of just outlawing billionaires.
It really is immoral.
I mean, I understand, you know,
you can make $900 million
and get through the year
with that as your income.
But the idea of a billionaire --
I was thinking about --
We were talking backstage here.
We're on 50th Street
and Sixth Avenue
here in New York City.
Two nights ago, a young mother,
22 years old,
at the subway stop
one block over
on Seventh avenue
and 50th Street,
trying to take her baby
down the stairs in the stroller,
and she falls and she dies.
The mother dies.
The baby lived,
but the mother died.
And I'm like -- This is the
richest country on the planet,
and we're in the richest city,
and we have a subway system
that is over 100 years old
and feels like
it's 200 years old.
And the fact
that we can't even provide
what you have in other cities
in this country,
but also throughout the world --
mass transit,
modern mass transit --
and she has to die struggling to
take a stroller down the stairs.
Nine blocks from us
right here --
go the other direction,
on 59th and Sixth Avenue --
a man just bought
the most expensive
home, dwelling, in America.
He spent $238 million
on his penthouse.
-Yeah.
-On Central Park South.
How could we just
nine blocks away have that
and allow this woman to die
because of an infrastructure
that has crumbled
and doesn't work?
If I were president,
I would fix that immediately.
I would not allow this kind
of disparity to continue.